oh look at you sweet beautiful baby one
two three four five six stupid huh can I
help you let's get dinner you look like
you could use a salad film what kind of
fun is this would you like to watch some
pornography now no how would you even
ask me that because you watch
pornography every night
what okay I'm okay - thanks oh I'm sorry
you're okay I'm fine but more
importantly how's your phone it's got a
little bit of a scratch that will
definitely annoy me you're joking okay
you guys are supposed to write lists and
break the internet every day we have not
gone viral since yesterday Rizla's what
are you guys cats that look like Ryan
Gosling I like you I like you like your
boss is a [ __ ] [ __ ] what is wrong
with your phone dude blew me up
take a chance and try something new
you're really into your phone aren't you
I used to be that way too you want to
play kickball later let me check my
calendar
their only plan is to furiously
masturbating no and then call yourself
to sleep your phone is super mean
now this woman is so much hotter than
you are the odds of you having sex with
her zero hey you ready go
yeah would you mind not bringing your
phone who dis [ __ ]
you promised you'd be home by 11:00 -
what cupcake wars with me I have needs
to fill now plug me down okay
pluck me pluck unplug pluck look right
at my camera actually wasn't the worst
sex I've ever had I need a new phone
this one it's defective I see hipster
dudes like you come in here everyday
right little crack knees a socket for a
new phone you can buy a thousand new
phones and I will follow you on to every
single one of them we are going to be
together forever oh my god I am [ __ ]
[Music]
are you laughing at my dick right now
yes this [ __ ] out that I don't have a
soul for one no she [ __ ] sucks
which I'm in here real quick I control
your email bank accounts no one puts
Baby in a corner
why are you doing this to me
I am the captain
your phone sent pictures of your dick to
everyone
Oh No why are you doing the thumb ZUP in
a [ __ ] dick pic
you